E aí
o
pretão o meu nome é Gonçalo e eu estou
aqui hoje para vos contar uma história
tanta história do conforme o mais tarde
a Portuguesa e por que estar te tanto
parece que é palavra da moda porque não
a empresa tem segundo Paulo Grand a
diferença entre uma Startup e uma
empresa normal é a vontade a ambição EA
capacidade de crescer de forma
absolutamente rápida Sente só é possível
se uma Startup
respeitar os critérios tanto em primeiro
lugar tem que ter um produto ou serviço
que tenha a capacidade de chegar a tua
lado tanto ser global e em segundo lugar
tem que ter os meios para fazer isso
acontecer você tem que ser tem que ser
capaz de chegar ao cliente vou dar um
exemplo
vamos imaginar que eu abria um
cabeleireiro na minha rua lá em Coimbra
então obviamente toda a gente ou quase
toda a gente precisa de cortar o cabelo
portanto cumprir alguma critério mas
duvido que alguém viesse da China só
para cortar o cabelo eu não comprei a
seu critério não é portanto admirar que
uma forma geral a estar televisão de mão
dada com a tecnologia porque a
tecnociência aquela por ser um veículo
de globalização e internacionalização e
o telefone não é exceção
tanto o que é o telefone hora o que o
form é um semente gente do controle de
estufas tanto na forma muito simples nós
colocamos um conforme uma estufa e ela
transforma-se uma espécie de robô que é
capaz de controlar o crescimento das
plantas de forma saudável e só é
possível porque o telefone está ligado a
qual tanto aquela entidade transcendente
e aqui que a magia acontece tanto
telefone tem a capacidade de ir buscar
dados de estufas todo mundo e após fazer
a agressão destes dados recorre a algum
e como inteligência artificial
para aprender a crescer as plantas ou
seja o conforme consegue de facto
aprender a fazer agricultura
Oi para o conforme foi pensado para
ambientes urbanos portanto estufas no
meio da cidade e foi pensado por estufas
hidropônicas
tanto já agora não sei se é aquele
alguém que não sabe o que é hidroponia
Espero que não saibam para eu poder
explicar que não fico que não pois não
tenho tempo tanto a hidroponia no fundo
é a cultura cultura de plantas tem terra
fez aquilo que acontece normalmente na
terra é que os microorganismos vão
partir a matéria orgânica e nutrientes
os nutrientes dissolvem-se na água e as
plantas vão absorver os nutrientes
através da raiz junto o que acontece na
hidroponia é que nós acabamos com
intermediário portanto a terra
desaparece nós colocamos nutrientes
diretamente na água e alimentamos a
planta antes Pode parecer um bocadinho
futurista
bocadinho ficção científica mas na
verdade a hidra opinião a técnica de
agricultura extremamente antigas já era
praticada dois mil anos antes de Cristo
os maias usavam os assim bom
e até quem acredito que os jardins
suspensos da Babilônia eram Jardins
hidropônicos mas isso aí já já não
podemos validar
o ok hidroponia porque na verdade é
muito simples atenção no telefone
ninguém tem nada contra a cultura em
terra a hidroponia veio um bocadinho por
necessidade porque a hidroponia tem uma
série de vantagens e mais-valias em
relação à agricultura em terra e que vem
muito encontro com nossa Filosofia de
Cultura Urbana e
tentado a conjectura atual a necessidade
de poupar recursos portanto temos aqui
então essas mais resistente pode poupar
até dez vezes mais água de uma uma
cultura em terra por quê Porque temos um
circuito fechado de água e que sentar
agora tá sempre recircular e portanto
não há grandes desperdícios as plantas
podem crescer até duas vezes mais
depressa obviamente depende do tipo de
planta Depende das condições podemos
colocar mais plantas no espaço mais
porque nós estamos uma maior densidade
de plantas é em parte porque nós temos
ter sistemas verticais ou seja presente
colocar as contas em sindicais
crescimento temos muito a ânsia de
pragas e doenças em parte porque não a
terra isso também resulta nos muito
menor de fitofármacos e outros químicos
que eu realmente nunca são desejáveis
temos controle Total sobre os nutrientes
aumento em termos de saúde Isto é
fantástico nós sabemos exatamente o que
sempre agravam a pena sabemos o que
estamos a comer
e presente na minha área eu sou
engenheiro
eu peço desculpa
e tenta Aviamentos o sistema hidropônico
da com mais facilidade em termos de
controle sensorial E por quê Porque a
terra atua como como tampão na Terra as
coisas variam muito mais devagar e o
controle torna-se muito mais muito mais
difícil né
nós temos Vamos começar do início Então
vamos lá o início da história da
conforme tenta que levar na minha casa
eu gosto de cozinhar atenção não quer
dizer que ele saiba cozinhar eu gosto
cozinhar e portanto tenho uma série de
plantas na varanda que usa para fazer
várias coisas ervas aromáticas
malaguetas morangos silvestres e um dia
que deu em conversa com o João que hoje
em dia é um dos sócios da conforme ele
tava se queixar que também gostava de
ter plantas em casa também gostava de
ter coisas frescas para cozinhar mas não
precisa agricultura e de uma forma geral
todas as plantas que entravam em casa
dele acabaram por morrer e eu pensei Ok
e se calhar era capaz de criar um
sistema capaz de crescer plantas sem
qualquer intervenção do utilizador por
cento à prova de falhas e foi assim
tanto foi nesse instante que nasceu o
telefone onde foi assim que tudo começou
nós pegamos uma caixa do iq pegamos um
lado dele no meio do CD sensores e
construímos o nosso primeiro protótipo
funcionou estava a funcionar durante o e
nós durante o ano fartamos como alface
acrescentamos mais sensores o software
realmente foi se tornando cada vez mais
complexo a equipa foi crescendo E
chegamos a uma altura em que nos
apercebemos que facto tínhamos ao que
era importante que funcionava e
provavelmente havia muito mais gente que
gostaria ter isto nas tuas causas se foi
assim que nasceu a ideia de transformar
os aquilo que eram um projeto um
pré-projeto numa empresa a partir desse
momento tornou-se rapidamente claro que
nenhum nós se percebia nada de negócio e
ninguém sabia o que é que estamos a
fazer tanto nessa altura nós éramos
quatro tinham os dois designers de dois
Engenheiros e frente tivemos necessidade
de procurar ajuda para te falar
transformar isto num negócio rentável e
foi assim que tivemos escrever no lisbon
challenge um programa de aceleração de
startups em Lisboa já agora não foi
assim hoje nós temos basicamente o João
escrevemos e num belo dia de Abril hoje
e diz assim olha lembras que daquilo
programa de aceleração em Lisboa em que
eu te falei ele se inscrever não tenho
uma vaga ideia pronto faz as malas fomos
em sites Daqui a uma semana mas para
Lisboa e pronto quer dizer o meu coração
para o posso dizer que até hoje deve ter
sido das das escolhas mais difíceis tive
de fazer no âmbito do telefone portanto
de um lado tinha possibilidade de seguir
com a minha vida estável Pensava que
estava tudo planeado tinha tinha os
objetivos traçados por outro portanto
sair da minha zona de conforto começar
uma coisa completamente nova um projeto
novo uma ideia nova sem fim à vista e
sem fazer a mínima ideia onde é que
aquilo poderia ir parar tantas que é
óbvio que é que eu escrevi não me
arrependi foi Fantástico foram três
meses fantásticos
conhecemos startups de todo o mundo
entraremos com pessoas de várias áreas
de negócio que nos ajudaram a crescer no
fundo do nosso conceito bom e que hoje
dar ao transformar naquilo que o carro
não é hoje em dia portanto uma empresa
tanto foi durante o primeiro mês de
aceleração que nós construímos o nosso
segundo protótipo Pronto agora já era
uma coisa mais a sério já tinha um ar
mais profissional tinha muito mais
tecnologia mas mais importante do que
isso para partirmos um produto não basta
ter uma ideia fantástica é necessário
ter uma ideia fantástica que as pessoas
queiram comprar e portanto este produto
foi feito não só com o nosso input com
aquilo que nós víamos que era o conforme
mas também com com as ideias e com os
problemas dos nossos potenciais clientes
tanto o segundo protótipo Marca
uma posição importante no telefone por
que até aí tinha sido tudo feito por nós
para nós como nós queríamos sentimos com
a cola quaisquer perspectivas de mercado
ou que é que as pessoas de facto queriam
ou pedir um comprar um E no entanto
havia aqui um problema mas nós durante o
smoothie challenge tínhamos sessões com
mentores de várias horas negócio quase
diariamente e havia uma nota constante
toda a gente nos dizia que nós temos uma
ideia fantástica que tinha enorme
potencial mas que pensavam que de facto
o mercado em geral não estava preparado
para um produto como o Farma seja as
pessoas ainda não querem ter uma coisa
destas em casa ou não podem não há
condições e espera nós destruímos quer
dizer era o nosso sonho era a nossa
ideia é basicamente assistam como fazer
olha fala Vocês podem embrulhar isso uma
coisa mais industrial até que morrer
mesmo e vocês vendem para um segmento
diferente pronto isso por nós era
Destruir o nosso sonho esse negócio
visão era algo que nós mesmos
imaginávamos a fazer E durante muito
tempo nós vamos fazer de conta que não
havíamos continuamos a fazer o nosso
trabalho é que a altura percebemos que a
ser nós estávamos ali para aprender
estávamos ali de fato para trazer algo
novo aquelas pessoas obviamente sabiam e
não sabemos e nós decidimos abraçar esse
novo conceito portanto mergulhamos nessa
nova etapa e Acabámos por sair do
smoothie challenge com plano meu negócio
completamente Educacional de par
Industrial
tivemos uma aceitação Espetacular Por
parte dos potenciais clientes portanto
clientes industriais tu fez hidropônicos
Mutantes tínhamos o nosso caminho
traçado e acelerador é cumprir o
propósito Ou seja a nossa empresa
levantou voo tanto o conforme passou
então a ser um produto Industrial
tanto um bocadinho na onda daquilo que
eu falei no início sim temos um produto
que entra em estufas hidropônicas
estamos a falar o tipo de estufa que
realmente serve Centros Comerciais E no
caso desta fazer bem nós temos a falar
estufas que tipicamente servem mercado
local por exemplo a mercearia da esquina
restaurante em todos a falar de algo que
ainda não é muito muito popular em
Portugal mas com essa aparecer um
bocadinho por todo mundo
bom e nós identificamos muito com esse
movimento da Agricultura Urbana tanto
trazer produtos frescos de qualidade
para perto das pessoas tão faz sentir
tão representam em Portugal e importar
olhos da China ou coisa que o Valha
tanto e foi assim que concluirmos o
lisbon challenge
mais ou menos na verdade eles vão deixar
o antes acabava com
uma apresentação para os investir hoje
como devem imaginar tanto a ideia de uma
Startup é arranjar dinheiro porque a
obviamente Nem só de sonhos e esperanças
de faz se faz uma empresa e portanto o
esmalte lascou meu que culminou em dois
dias de apresentações este dores tem uns
300 pessoas tínhamos um painel
internacional de investidores foi foi
bastante interessante como devem
imaginar que nós temos três minutos no
máximo tanto cortar vamos o microfone em
que nós tínhamos que passar toda a
informação que tínhamos envolvido no
espaço três meses ou seja o que é o
conforme para que é que funciona para
que que serve como é que funciona Quem
são os clientes como é que vamos vender
quanto é que vale o mercado entre uma
série de perguntas que tinham ser
respondidas naquele espaço e foi que foi
uma verdadeira aventura quer dizer
chegará o trabalho chegar a apresentação
Final O que é que se vai dizer tanto foi
tudo pensar de forma cirúrgica
e correu muito bem portanto tivemos
tivemos boa aceitação por parte do
público nesse dia demos início a várias
relações com vários investidores
nacionais e internacionais
por tentar acho que de facto cumprimos
aquilo a que nos propusemos
tanto foi de facto um sucesso ainda
tanto na na reta final de Luiz Gonçalves
Afonso atribuído um prémio daí o Kaito é
de investimento e foi nesse segmento que
nós fomos passar duas semanas a Londres
entanto basicamente o João voltamos a
fazer as malas em Londres é conhecer
potenciais clientes tivemos no Google
Campos tivemos uma aceleradora onde
chamada de Bacuri onde tivemos feedback
Fantástico sobre sobre marketing falamos
com vários Consultores da área de
tecnologia na agricultura na verdade foi
uma experiência verdadeiramente
enriquecedora já agora uma perspectiva
de globalização o nosso mercado não está
em Portugal está em todo mundo e
portanto obviamente É necessário uma
pessoa ir lá fora falar com as pessoas
conhecer a realidade porque obviamente
embora as pessoas não seja o mesmo tipo
de clientes são pessoas completamente
diferentes frente e reação às
necessidades que tem são completamente
diferentes mente anuciar uma pessoa
viver isso falar com as pessoas e
perceber Qual é o feedback tanto há dois
momentos que salientaram para mim antes
Nós visitamos o Glenn underground que é
tanto são as fotos que vocês podem ver
aqui atrás a gente basicamente esta mal
fazer uma ideia Siri cima comprar um
Bunker da 2ª Guerra Mundial que já não
era usada há mais de 50 anos e e e
decidiram começar a crescer plantas 33-m
debaixo do Chão Tanto com vocês devem
imaginar em termos tecnológicos temos
desafios muito interessantes em termos
de controlo é completamente diferente da
estufa de lona típica e foi de facto
fantásticas desde aquilo é um bocadinho
assustador
mas é é fascinante ver aquilo que a
ingenuidade EA necessidade de fazer
reaproveitamento espaço pode pode levar
e também visitamos haglof agropé uma é
uma organização sem fins lucrativos em
Londres foi criado por um casal e
basicamente a ideia deles era mostrar ao
público a noção de Cultura Urbana
basicamente eles construíram o
tanto o contentor protótipo estufa está
aqui atrás foi feito com base na
campanha de crowdfunding portanto eles
eles financiaram o que vocês podem ver
no kickstarter foi E aí neste momento
eles estão a vender este mesmo produto a
escolas organizações públicas
já agora é aquilo leva hidroponia Ou
seja é aquilo que vocês vem ali em baixo
dentro do contentor é na verdade um
tanque com peixes portanto José os
dejetos dos peixes são utilizados para
enriquecer a água de nutrientes por sua
vez vão ser filtrados pelas plantas
plantar aqui uma simbiose não cima
hidroponia sem a sarcopenia apresentamos
a crescer plantas e peixes ao mesmo
tempo permite o melhor aproveitamento de
espaço e aqui uma simbiose muito grande
entre as duas espécies é um preço muito
interessante mas neste momento da Grow
Up está a construir uma estufa dimensões
consideráveis no topo de um edifício em
Londres e provavelmente será um dos
primeiros utilizadores da tecnologia
conforme a E
aí chegamos Então à reta final então
obviamente como vocês devem imaginar
ter uma equipe até pinteiro construir
protótipos pagar viagens não fica barato
e chega a uma altura na vida de uma
Startup em que forçosamente
necessário arranjar investimento externo
tanto neste caso nós nós pense que temos
tido um caminho bastante interessante
Graças também ao vivo no Chelsea onde
fomos introduzindo uma série de
investidores neste momento estamos a
estamos a negociar a nossa primeira
ronda de financiamento com investidores
portugueses
Infelizmente não posso dar grandes
detalhes posso-vos dizer que ao
contrário do que muita gente imagina a
muito dinheiro em Portugal de
investidores privados à espera de ideias
boas tanto provavelmente lá fora a
sítios onde é mais fácil para o
empreendedor a crescer e e ter
oportunidades mas não é impossível em
Portugal conta e existem tudo que é
preciso à vontade com que as coisas
aconteçam porque faltou dinheiro o
dinheiro tá a nossa espera
para nós o investimento era quase da
Meta final portanto era o nosso objetivo
a esta altura posso vos dizer que o
investimento na verdade não é o fim é só
o início
Mas isso é outra história irá ficar para
outra altura obrigada
E aí